Oh yeah. What's up everybody, I'm Ollie
your Real Life English Fluency coach.
You asked for it and we've delivered. Today
you're learning English with Shawn mendes.
Whether you're part of the Mendes army or not
you can't deny that Shawn is one of the biggest
Pop stars today. If you watch all of this video
you're going to learn how Shawn feels before he
goes on stage and some useful dating expressions
but before we get started I want to tell you
that we help you learn English with your
favorite celebrities TV series and movies
without getting lost without missing the jokes and
without subtitles. just as Rohit who says that our
channel is the best for improving your English. So
join over 6 million learners from around the world
by hitting that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Do you struggle to understand fast speaking
natives? Then I highly recommend our Fluent
with Friends Course. In this 48 week course you
are going to learn with the first two seasons
of Friends. Every week you will receive PDF
Power Lessons Vocabulary Memorization Software
and access to our Fluency Circle Global Community
and so much more. The best part is you can try it
absolutely free with our three part Master Class.
To try it out today simply click up
here or down in the description below.
Mastering discourse markers will
help you understand fast speaking
natives. So I highly recommend you
check out this lesson that we made.
To watch it next simply click up here
or down in the description below.